-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my in-box,
return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
I was running
a bit behind today.
I was just wondering,
can I write out some weekly
thank-you notes right now?
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you-
note-writing music, please?
[ Piano plays ]
What's he doing?
Is he chewing something?
-I think he's had
his second Maple Pepsi.
-He's, like, hiding something
in his mouth.
-Is it a bird?
Is a bird in there?
-I don't know what it is.
He had a jalapeño slice
of pizza, maybe, earlier.
-Pizza pie?
-Yeah, pizza pie.
-Spicy pizza pie.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, Oscar pools,
for giving me a chance to win
back some of the money I lost
on my March Madness bracket.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
I lost so much ApeCoin,
you have no idea.
-How much ApeCoin did you lose?
-Oh, my God, I lost like...
35 Jimmy Bucks'
worth of ApeCoin.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, picture from
this week's NATO summit,
for letting me know
what it'd look like
if Brooks Brothers sponsored
a new "We Are the World."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ There comes a time ♪
♪ When we heed a certain call ♪
[ Notes play ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, Harry Styles'
new album cover
for "Harry's House,"
for looking like
that moment you realized
you built the IKEA backwards.
You go --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, March,
for feeling like someone
put the weather on shuffle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like I --
Come on!
"It's beautiful today!"
-It's 20!
-Wearing a turtleneck.
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, senioritis,
for being, by far,
the best "itis" you can have
after spring break.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, March Madness,
for going from
"I hope I win my office pool"
to "I'll just be happy
if Chad from HR loses."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why?
-Wow, you hate Chad.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, birdhouses,
or as the Airbnb listing
calls it,
"kind of a hole in the wall."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, Questlove,
for being nominated
for an Academy Award
for Best Documentary...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...and for being
the only nominee
who could end their speech
by playing their own
wrap-it-up music.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good luck to you, buddy.
There you have it.
Those are our thank-you notes.